[Music]
now Aussie has started driving he didn't
that when I first met Aussie he did not
drive and start strut what kind of
driver is awesome oh he's absolutely
awful I mean awful really really bad yes
oh you passed the test I think he
probably gave the guy free tickets to
the show or something like that right
okay yes okay so now Aussies out there
driving in Los Angeles and you should
all take note really he's out there Oh
some it's he's not good uh and he
doesn't like to drive at night no I
don't want him to drive at night nobody
wants him to drive it no one wants him
driving
I don't just stop that I'm disgusted I'm
with you believe me I'm like this the
whole time he puts on the brake and he
throws you forward and he's like you get
in the car with him when he goes I
wouldn't do that I have to take care of
my husband with those huge we like an
air bag we mentioned this next week
America's Got Talent
airs Monday Tuesday and Wednesday at 9
p.m. on NBC and the talk airs weekdays
on every day you know I'm on the tour
yes I love that you enjoy that I do um
and I just wanted to briefly mention
because I've met your son Jack and we're
concerned from hoping that he's well I
know that he got a I know psious of
earlier in the week was it last week a
um it's actually been a month that's
been a movie kept it yeah to ourselves
for a month but he it's doing so amazing
he is so strong and positive and yes
yeah he's my son will conquer
we're just telling just because I've met
him any such a sweet person and I'm
really a big kind of his telling that
we're all sending our love and
positivity and all because it means so
much I'm so yeah well thank you so much
for being here too and please say hi to
Aussie as well you know I will yes you
will
Sharon Osbourne we'll be right back